Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to the Five Nights at Candy's 3 demo!
Now the developer was trying to get the full game out before the end of the year...
but unfortunately it looks like there was a delay,
but now I get to play the demo. I've played both Five Nights at Candy's 1 and 2
so I'm kind of excited to play this one because it has not been a disappointment
it's been a pretty good one, but then again this is just a demo
*reading* Look around with the mouse, you can look to the sides and also up and down
look down and two buttons will appear, the blue button turns you to the tape player? The red button lets you look underneath the bed
uh ok? If the monster attacks hold the flashlight in the monster's eyes until it goes away
if the monster goes under your bed, *panicked voice* find out which side the bed it is hiding under
*really fast and scared* then while not looking under the bed look in the other direction of the bedroom
to lure the monster to peek out from under the bed
when you hear it peeking out turn to the other side of the bed - I don't know what the hell you're talking about!
playing the music tape in the tape player makes the night go much faster
it is possible to survive the night without using the - I don't know, I'm not gonna -OH GOD
oh I'm not gonna win this
Oh I am not gonna win this
Oh I am NOT gonna win this
HO - hi... HII! :)
HELLO!
Is that me, back when I had black hair?
Oh boy... oh
Oh-OH GOD
OH NO
THE ROOM IS SO BIG
(soft whimper comes from mark)
OH GOD NO
*clicks button* euh *tape whirring* euh
*singing* lalala~ EUHUEHUEHE oh my god
I don't liKE THIS AT ALL!
*clicking buttons* ok...
is he here- oh fuck god
hey hey hEY HEY HEY HEY
I SAW THAT !!!!
I SAW ALL OF THAT !!!!!!!!!!
YOU BRING NONE OF THAT IN MY HOUSE!!!!
euh shit- why is this - why is this goddamn room so fricking big
it's so big
*In an not so reassuring tone*Okay
so... i noticed the tape player - fucking STOP!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE YET! CALM DOWN!
oh boy
*whimpers* oh boy..
I am - *bad british accent* I might be in a spot of bother
oh boy - that's no good, that's not good
*knocking sounds* What was that??? *slight panic*
*terrified* Hi, hello  - WHAT,  hi-
and where and WHAT - I hear noises
but I see NOTHING!
oh sheetu
oh shit
Ok, well - that's good, I think it's under the bed
NOPE
*Spooked* Not under the bed!
Oh boy - I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, OH GOD I'm dead
OH GOD
Urgh.  WHY? HELLO
I, th- I SAW SOMETHING BUT I STILL HAVEN'T SEEN YOU!
oh god - I gotta like, I gotta like play the tape again I-I g- I guess
REWIND?
*Begins Rewinding*
huededada *various tape noises*
huedebuede NO
*various tape noises*
*Music plays*
H'OKAY - hello?
oh boy
well that's not good
*Scared* Oh
*music still playing in background*
ah ah ay - HEY!
Oh Hi!
WHOOOAAAHH OK
Yeah, look into the flashlight
Does that bother you? Are you bothered by that? I think I remember you-
*loud noises* WHOA
Ah, that's not good
how?
AM I DEAD?
I might be dead
I might be very dead
OH hi- hello - hi - ok
*Thunder Noises* ALRIGHT OKAY ALRIGHT I don't know what that was all about!
Ok, bye - *relieved* okay, alright. cool. great.
good- good havin' you visit
Oh I love it when company comes over
Now if you could go fuck yourself and never come back that'd be great too :)
Alright, cooool
oh boy
Oh boy I'm - I'm boned
I'm boned
*loud blanket noises*  ok anyway, let's rewind that
*more tape recorder noises*
And take this calmly one step at a time until we die
that's not good - That's not a good sign. That's a bad sign
That's one of them bad s- HEY FUCKING FUCKING STOP THAT
SAME PLACE BEING BULLSHIT HAVING MOUSE SHAKING PIECE O' ASS BITING
euh- DICKATRY
JUST FUCK OFF AND FUCK YOU AND GO TO HELL AND DIE
goddamn it- ee ok
well, he's under my bed
that's nice
oh'kay, where ya at buddy boo?
Where ya at?
*high-pitched* whe-RE YA AT BUDDY BOO?
oh- *screams of hell and hearts skips a beat*FUCKING GODDAMN IT I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BEAT YOU
*old man voice* THANK YOU(Nice old man voice)
ok, well game over I died, that's great here I go again, having to try one more time
FUCKING fantastic, ok
SO THAT IS..... DIFFICULT
That is very difficult
That's VERY Difficult
hokay
So.... I don't know how to beat that but I'll try again:)
Ooh, I'll try again
Oh I get it, this is from the perspective of the monster
looking in on the room
ah yeah death - ok death I get it death
it's gonna play that
make the night go much faster (ish)
sure wish I could turn my head faster that would be of great help to everybody involved here
ha ha HA haha
ok come on, COME ON, COME AT ME I'M HERE
COME AT ME BRO
I'M READY
UH
oh- OH!
IT'S ME whu- IT'S ME!
Oh I did not notice that!
Oh that's so cool!
I'm in the game! I have red hair... I don't have that anymore HAHAHA
oh shit
oh fuck oh fuck HEY FUCKING GODDAMN IT WHY ARE YOU THERE?
DON'T DO THAT
Alright so, I guess- I guess after this phase
he's gotta- I gotta- I gotta look under the bed?
WHICH DOESNT SEEM LIKE A GOOD IDEA I WANNA STRESS THAT FACT
here we go!
*weird noise* WHEEY ALRIGHT YOU'RE ON THAT SIDE
so I gotta look over here
then look back
oh quickly quickly quickly
ok, that's not good
ok, get laDIDADIDADIDA
~lookin' over ther- *JUMPSCARED!*  FUCK *sounds of hell* FUCKING FUCK
Alright, so that's fucking impossible :(
So I guess I can't look over as far
but that is a thing-  alright I'm going to give it another go
I'm going to give like at least two more go's before I give up on this
Remember. this is just a demo, this isn't the full game
The full game is going to be released at some point in the future
very soon, hopefully in the next month, BUT
This is just a DEMO / Dunno if I can BEAT it
*raspy voice*Don't know how to PLAAAY~
oh! heard that
heard that, heard that, heard that
heard that, ok, heard that
heard somethin'- oh HEEY OKAAY Alright I see it
ok
I see ya
So there's like
K-I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY MEAN BY ALOT FASTER
But-
The night is definitley not going ALOT faster with the music
ooh shit
ok, he's somewhere
ok so that- ooh did I? I did! I didn't notice, but apparently I saw him so lemme just
get this a rewindin'
*rewinding tap noises*
ok, alright, ok, alright, ok *incoherant 'okay's' and 'alrights'*
*getting slowly quieter* okie dokie, okie dokie, okie dokie
rewind and get back up quickly quickly quickly quickly
Ok
I-I really don't know if that's helping at all
It seems like the night is still verry, very long
Like, VERY very long night here so I don't know
What it's doing to help me
K, but I think...
Play...
So I'm just gonna do it anyway, cus I'm- apparently I'm asleep!
According to somebody...
Woah... Heard that
Woah shit- HEY FUCKING NONONONONONONONONONO STAHP (x8)
No I'm gonna beat YOU
Ah you beat ME? NO
That is just very- NO
Fuck. Okay.
So he's under the bed, so I just gotta peak under, see what side
Peek *scary noise*
Whoa, I think he's on the right I guess?
Oah, fuck I didn't see, fuck
Okay, he's on the right
Okay, so I just gotta look over here- lalalala
Looking awaay, looking BACK
Looking awaaaay, looking BACK
*jumpscare*
FUCKING WHAT? I FUCKING DID IT!
I DID THE THING IT SAID!
Goddammit!
Alright, one more try!
ONE more try!
*reading* If the monster attacks, hold the flashlight on the monster's eyes until it goes away. If the monster goes under your bed-
Well, it's almost impossible to make him go away
*reading* Find out which side of the bed he's hiding under. Then while not looking under the bed, look in the other direction of the bedroom to lure the monster to peek out from under the bed.
When you HEAR it peeking out, turn to the other side of the bedroom then strike it with your flashlight.
Oooooooow okay I guess... *understands finally what to do*
"When you hear it peeking out..."
Alright, one more go! One more try, one more try. I got this.
Maybe not. I don't got this. I probably- I definitely don't got this.
I 100% don't got this!
Where you goin', where you goin', where you goin', what you doin', what you do-
Ah, I SEE you!
K. Gonna PLAY my TAPE! Gonna PLAY my FUN TAPE. It's a FUN TAPE full of FUN TIMES!
It's also got some FUCK YOU'S in there!
'Tis my FUN FUCK TAPE!
Blaah, that's bad for a-
I don't have a FUN FUCK tape
*Unintelliglible speak*
I'm bailing out this joke
I'm bailing- nope, backflippin' out of this joke. This is not a good joke
I should shut up
Baah, shut up is what I should do, I'm not shutting up though
That's not what I'm doing
I'm still talking actually
Surprisingly I'm still talking
*knock knock* woah, hello
*Scary music* K hai fucking STOP NOO
Gonna win this time
You're gonna looose, you're gonna lose, you're gonna lose
What- come on!
Okay, fine! Alright, where ya at?
*scare* woah! Okay, you're on that side huh?
So I'm just gonna...
Oooh...
Hehe. GOT YA! HAHA HA!
Okay, alright
I get it. I get it now!
Buh-bye!
Okay. Fine. FUCK YOU
Woo, heard that
There ya are. Yeah I heard ye. Yeah I heard ye. Gotta play my tape now 'cos apparently it's still only 2 AM!!
Fucking night stays forever
Yea I'm halfway through!
*mumbles* You can fuck yoursehelf!
FUCK YOURSEELF!
Go FUUCK yourseelf!!
Where you goin'? Where you goin'?
Whooa. I see you! I SAW THAT!
Tryin' to hide in my closet
Get out of there R-Kelly rat
Stands for Rat Kelly... That's a bad joke again
God Damnit! I need to stop doing that!
It's a high stress situation!
I CAN'T MAKE GOOD JOKES!
Heyyy... yep!
You're going away. That's what you're gonna be doing.
You're not gonna go anywhere
So, I kinda got the strategy down
As soon as you hear the steps,
you gotta go to one extreme,
whatever extreme you're closest to
and then you gotta hit that
and immediately go back and he'll be in the other one
Woah! What the fuck was that?
Doon't do surprises!
I am just explaining the strategems here!
Fucking do not do that.
I am in a controlled enviroment
Not gonna fuck with me.
Fucking stoop that
Where are you?
FUCKING STOP IT! GOD DAMNIT!
I'm gonna winn!
You're gonna lose!
Gonna lose, gonna lose. You're gonna lose
You're gonna lose x4
You're gonna lose x2
Fucking God damnit!
Okay, here we go
Don't, don't kill me
If you kill me I will fuck yooou
The fuck up. Alright
ooooooooo
*silence*
*high voice* Gotcha. hehehehehehehehehehehehehehehehe
Goodbyyyyyye
Fffffricko
hehehehe
okay, so I'm not even gonna bother rewinding it again
after this because I'm pretty sure
......
there's not enough time
oh shit
There you are! haha! got ya
Got ya!
*quieter* got ya
k
alright
Yeah not even gonna bother rewinding it
Not even gonna bother
*quiet* not gonna bother
maybe I should bother
I should probably bother
Oh, hey. I'm gonna bother
I'm gonna bother rewinding it!
Be kind! Rewind! You know
It's always a good,
it's, it's good habit to have
euhh jeez
*very quiet* oh boy
*Loud Knocking*
Fucking what?
Hii
Okay! Thanks for announcing it!
*incoherent speech*
I mean you're no- *Alarm rings*
Yaaaay! I did it!
*happy* That was as hard as 20 mode!
Ah! No it was NOT but okay
It was still pretty good
I liked it
End of the demo! See you soon
Okay, yes with your -
ugly ass Frankenstein tail
You are a lovely person and i love you a lot
So anyway!
It's actually good to see this because
it's been a long time
since I played Five Nights at Candy's 1 or 2
I played them at the beginning of last year
so this is the beginning of this year now
so, it's kinda nice to see it come around
and with an interesting mechanic
I mean,
having the double wide room is
kinda disconcerting and I like that but
there's some cool stuff that can be done with this
I just think there might need to be
a few more characters,
I'm hoping there are gonna be
or maybe it's gonna be a Springtrap style thing but -
we'll see what happens when the full game gets released, so,
THANK YOU EVERYBODY so much for watching
Let me know if you want a full playthrough of that
when it comes out and as -
woah - hang on a second
I see those buttons!
Hey, if you look behind
I'm gonna brighten this in post
but I think I seesomething
There's buttons there
I see that!
And I see you!
so, Thank you again everybody
and let me know dow-down in the comments below
and as always! I will see you -
In the next video!
BYE BYE!
*outro music plays*